Americans will vote tomorrow in a
midterm election that is largely seen as
a referendum on president Trump and his
first 22 months in office the president
campaigned all weekend holding rallies
in Georgia and Tennessee yesterday and
today he'll go to Cleveland Fort Wayne
Indiana and Cape Girardeau Missouri to
rally Republican voters his predecessor
former President Obama has also been on
the campaign trail to try and fire up
the Democratic Party's base and he heads
to Virginia today more than 34 million
Americans have already cast a ballot and
early voting that's an increase of more
than 50% over the 20 2014 midterms our
CBS News battleground tracker found
two-thirds of voters think this election
matters just as much as the 2016
presidential vote another quarter say
the midterms matter even more
we have correspondence across the
country watching the most important
races and here in studio 57 were joined
by our own Nancy Cordes and Anthony
selves Ando we begin though with major
Garrett at the White House major an
important week indeed good morning to
you good morning to you the atmosphere
here at the White House edgy and
uncertain anticipation on the Senate
side a fair measure of dread looking at
the House races here at the White House
there's a sense that two or three Senate
seats could be picked up by Republicans
possibly more but they know here at the
White House House losses will be
suffered the big question will the
president's frenetic campaign schedule
be enough to save the House Republican
majority nobody here seems to know for
sure I need you to vote for a Republican
House and a Republican Senate at
multiple rallies Sunday the president
relied on economic gains and border
fears they want to impose socialism on
our country we will keep the criminals
drug dealers and terrorists the hell out
of our country
a new CBS News battleground tracker poll
shows more than 7 in 10 voters say their
vote will be about President Trump 34
percent say they will vote to support
the president 38 percent say they will
vote to oppose him there's so many
people in the house it's very hard to
make those tough before leaving the
White House for to Sunday rallies the
president again focused on the Senate as
a protective barrier against a blue wave
in the house my primary focus has been
on the Senate I think we're doing really
well in the Senate former President
Obama joined the weakened political
frenzy with a rally for vulnerable
Indiana Democratic Senator Joe Donnelly
you get to vote in what I believe will
be the most important election
of our lifetimes on that the two
presidents different in so many ways
almost agreed I don't know if I rate it
more important than the last election 16
but it's so most it's right there but
their partisan differences remain clear
they've racked up enough indictments to
feel the football team nobody in my
administration got indicted the
Democrats want to turn back the clock
throw America in reverse and return
power to a corrupt selfish ruling class
five people associated with mr. Trump or
his campaign have been indicted as was
mentioned three campaign rallies today
the most aggressive midterm presidential
campaign push in nearly 30 years
whatever the result need of the
president's energy nor his strident
immigration rhetoric will be forgotten
John a indeed major thanks so much